la journée d'investiture d'un président
de la république c'est une cérémonie qui
est extrêmement protocolaire extrêmement
cadré et qui laisse finalement très peu
de marge de manoeuvre pour un président
élu pour se démarquer donner une touche
personnelle à son mandat mais malgré
tout ça peut être aussi l'occasion de
signaler par une petite douche un geste
une orientation d'envoyer un symbole un
signal à au pays alors en matière de
gestes personnel il y à un monument qui
est indépassable c'est l'investiture de
françois mitterrand en 80 quand ils
remontent vers le panthéon avec des
roses à la main pour les fleurir les
tombes de jean jaurès victor schoelcher
et jean moulin donc il y à la gauche
l'abolition de l'esclavagé et la
résistance 7 ce geste là de françois
mitterrand il est indépassable personnes
depuis lui n'a réussi à marquer une
cérémonie d'investiture avec autant de
autant de force ils ont essayé quand
même laissé ses successeurs jacques
chirac a été se recueillir sur la tombe
du général de gaulle à colombey les deux
églises nicolas sarkozy en 2007 va au
monument de la résistance dans le bois
de boulogne et c'est là qu'il annonce
que les la lettre de guy môquet du
résistant guy môquet sera lu dans toutes
les écoles de france ô à la rentrée
scolaire je n'ai jamais pu
lire ou écouter la lettre de guy môquet
sans en être profondément bouleversé
et je voudrais dire aux français que ma
première décision de président de la
république soit demander au futur
ministre de l'éducation nationale que
cette lettre soit lure début d'année à
tous les lycéens de france pour nicolas
sarkozy c'est une façon de se plonger
dans l'histoire de france est de retenir
de mettre le doigt sur sept c'est cet
aspect de l'histoire qu'est la
résistance française tout au long de son
mandat la résistance fera partie de la
laddh la toile de fond de son ses
références historiques françois hollande
lui avait décidé de rendre hommage à
jules ferry et marie curie et en
seulement aujourd'hui la mémoire de
jules ferry
on a trois
l'intégration
ou la jeunesse les enseignants dont on
sait que c'est l'électorat traditionnel
de la gauche depuis marie curie la
recherche et en même temps
l'égalité femmes-hommes quant à elle
mêle macron alors lui il avait visité
l'hôpital militaire de percy il avait
rendu visite à des militaires blessés
mails macron est quelqu'un qui vient
d'une génération qui n'a pas fait son
service militaire et qui se retrouve
propulsé
du jour au lendemain presque par
effraction lui-même utilise ce terme
chef des armées chef des armées et bien
il fallait qu'il fasse un geste en ce
sens et c'est pour ça qu'il va aller
rendre visite à ses soldats blessés
parce que eh bien maintenant c'est lui
le chef des armées